So it's really great for
startups who are getting
started with Google Analytics.
There's a default implementation
that allows them to get started
really quickly and
easily with some key features that
they'll get to get right off the bat.
The first one is the number
of users in sessions.
The second is session duration,
they can know their operating systems,
the device models, and geography.
So, right off the bat they don't
have to do much because they get
that information right
off when they set it up.
After that,
that's when they can go even more deeper
to get some more details about users.
Things like who are more likely
to buy in-app purchases,
people who are stopping at a certain
level for game specific app.
Or if someone who just drops off and
hasn't use the app in the long time.